i was told to leave at 1 30. wow
so we're in a date today we're in extra
time did you do springs movie
i did uh i did a 6 30 protest and a
8 30 protest did you do that
all right
of your life
morning it was the weirdest one she's
talking about the protest
the wake-up call protest
but yeah 20 seconds is
what's up
context
oh ellie just listened to the vote back
and said garner voted
for it what gardner voted for it
she said she just listened to the vote
back and he voted yes
okay oh really yeah because i mean i was
in the gallery i was in there when
uh they were hanging off and he they
said he wouldn't know you got it now
and that's what the sheet that's what
our own
alexa is coming hey okay
the sheep
[Music]
affirmative
that that was corrected
yeah okay thank you
okay
[Music]
um
yeah that's a lot i'm sorry
it would have been fine without
technical difficulties
since there's like almost raw
represented here it's like
more than one yeah
and you should have told him that he set
the rolls with the curry
films of the courier that was i spent
like
almost two hours trying to figure that
out it's definitely on there
yeah like oh yeah you should send it to
a different
server yeah
come on i'm not going to tell you where
to send the pictures to them on sunday
there's just a lot of moving pieces
oh really they've gotten breaches they
had slack before
when they got breached and they got
their ftp reached so i don't know where
i can i can tell you every ftp password
on top of my
is it's not so hard to design a server
that can be
whatever what's that yeah
yeah i love you yeah yeah there you go
so like one of those like apple made
passwords it's like
16 characters long it's not like news
photos
oh no we all get that with everybody
you've sent it to the client you worked
for last week and then you have to
embarrassingly email them
no problem yeah but someone will
accidentally move them
that happened yesterday i heard yeah
it was funny
don't try to walk back what you said off
tonight
um
hmm
oh he's here now it says
what's up guys
okay
hello everybody
well today we saw the big difference
between senate democrats
and senate republicans senate democrats
want to protect american people's health
care they want to make sure
we want to make sure that 130
million americans who have pre-existing
conditions
including those who have contracted
covet
can get protection from rapacious
insurance companies that might want to
rip their health care away from them
republicans were willing to say the heck
with you american
people the heck with you we're siding
with the big special interests and we're
not going to protect you
republicans had a golden opportunity
today the republican senate leader
mcconnell
to make sure that the administration
didn't pursue this suit that would take
away
americans health care and of course
they sided with the big special
interests and
refused the american people will hear
this
loud and clear this is a stark division
between the parties
they didn't want to vote on this i had
to actually go to the floor when no
republican was on the floor
and asked for to put this bill in play
and they feared it they tried to jump
through a pretzel last night
because they're so afraid of this bill
that didn't work
and now they're trying today to say that
this doesn't matter
well yes it does and i'd say one final
thing
this is a one-two
view or rather this is a one-two punch
to the american people
first vote against our motion
to protect americans health care second
vote for judge amy coney barrett
who wants to take away your health care
every every every action of the
republicans
shows shows what side they're on
and the american people will see it loud
and
clear ready for your questions
senator so you know obviously you've
been trying to make a point here against
uh and putting vulnerable republicans on
i'm trying to put the republican party
in the senate don't put words in my
mouth
sorry okay okay in any event uh
obviously several
vulnerable republicans uh five six
altogether republicans voted for your
bills
and that would give them a lot of
political cover to say
they support pre-existing conditions was
this a mistake this um
let me just say we knew that they would
be new that some of them would squirm
but when you flip your vote a few weeks
before the election
the american people see right through it
these senators are worse off today no
matter
how they voted because they flip-flopped
they were against protecting
pre-existing conditions they were for
the lawsuit
and now three weeks before the election
they try to say they're for it and
working it out so there's not enough
votes to actually
have it have effect they can't hide from
all their votes to repeal the aca
and this new vote only shows their
hypocrisy
a few weeks before the election and
let me say this the american people will
also
see any senator who who votes
for judge amy coney barrett they will
see the hypocrisy
of those who said this vote shows them
for
protecting americans health care and
then they vote for a judge
who is intent on ripping it apart we
believe
this will hurt them badly because
their position is clear it never works
to flip your position a few weeks before
the election when you're forced to
yes um i talked with senator mcconnell
this morning he said
quote preexisting conditions are not in
jeopardy before the supreme court he
added that
is a completely bogus issue he says also
it's extremely unlikely that the supreme
court will even deal
with that part of obamacare law i wanted
to get your reaction
that is not what legal experts across
the country democrat and republican
believe
mcconnell is squirming this is an issue
where they know
the american people are on our side this
is a position where they know
that americans want their health care
protected
and they just you know try to create
diversions
when it comes to coney barrett try to
create diversions when it comes to this
bill
they're stuck and we stuck it and they
are stuck
and they're not going to get out of
their morass
might there be an opportunity to offer
amendments and if so what kind if
there's a stimulus that comes
to the senate floor uh in order to slow
down
the confirmation process or add rules or
do something
we will as i said we're going to use
every tool in the toolbox
to try and slow things down because we
think rushing through this nomination
while the election
is already ongoing is so so very wrong
um the problem of course is mcconnell
under his defiling the senate has
limited the number of tools that are
in that toolbox are you worried
um it sounds like the more you try to
employ your tools moving forward
they're going to and keep if you're
going to try to keep the senate here
they're going to put more red you know
conservative judges
um before you district judges is that is
that just
here because there are two issues before
us that are of vital importance
one is covet where the negotiations
ongoing in the house right now
and the second is the supreme court
nomination and we want to be here to do
what we can
to oppose it they would approve those
seven judges in lame duck session anyway
okay so and then also have you seen them
uh the latest
uh minutiae and counteroffer what where
do you think i haven't seen it i spoke
to speaker pelosi a few minutes ago
and they're not in an agreement yet they
have a lot of issues of disagreement
yes on that issue um do you
think that there is the possibility that
there will be some sort of agreement
between pelosi
and mnuchin and are you gonna come are
you gonna join those
conversations at some point just as when
it started in the senate
it was mnuchin and i sitting in the
office but we constantly
nancy and i constantly talk the same
thing is happening now we talk four or
five times a day
and look we want an agreement but it's
got to meet the needs of the american
people
and there are a lot of places right now
where the offer by secretary mnuchin
doesn't do that
are you worried about it might i try to
call no no let's see anyone didn't have
a question
okay we'll take one more um are there
any kinds of
i know you said your tools are limited
but are there any kinds of messaging
amendments that you could use at least
to be able to tell voters you know
here's what's at stake and here's what
we're trying to get what happened today
i mean it's a serious amendment but it
sure sends a message from one end of
america to the other that mcconnell and
the republican senate leadership
is against protecting americans health
care we're going to look for
lots of tools uh stay tuned can you
really say that though when six
republicans voted for you
it sounds like your bill got bipartisan
support look
again you flip-flop three weeks before
the election the american people have
seen through that
time and time again they don't trust the
vote three weeks before the election
when the candidates have been under
assault
on this issue and we are confident the
republicans no matter which way they
voted
because on the one side is trump and the
trump supporters and the other side
are so many of the american people no
matter which way they voted
they showed their hypocrisy and their
distance from the american people we're
confident of that
thank you okay last one her parents
nomination what will it mean for women's
reproductive rights and what do you make
of gop
accusations saying dems are attacking
barrett over her fate no dim has
attacked barrett over her faith it's a
diversion
because they don't want to address the
issues including health care
including roe v wade i think roe v wade
if judge barrett got on the court
could either be eliminated or at the
very minimum
horrible minimum so greatly constricted
that you'd never recognize it
thank you everybody
yeah good question
thank you
thank you
are we clear
okay we just want to make sure